prüfung tag und goethe staat deutsch 1
komplette vokabular mit dialogen
aktion 3
rund 40 wörter
los geht's
ich mein'
die familie die familien
der opa die opas
die oma die omas
tot
ich bin martin
das ist meine familie
mein opa heißt hans
meine oma ist schon lange tot
die eltern
beide
der vater die väter
die geschwister
meine eltern arbeiten beide noch
mein vater
bücher
mein vater verkauft bücher
meine mutter ist lehrerin
ich habe leider keine geschwister
und
die tochter
die töchter
der lkw
die lkws
lastkraftwagen
werden
peter und helmut sind meine söhne
und helmut sind meine söhne
das ist meine tochter katharina
sie will lkw-fahrerin werten
sieben lkw fahrerin werden
der deutsche
die deutschen
der schweizer die schweizerin
die schweizer
schweizerinnen
der türke die türken die türken die
türkinnen
wir sind alle schweizer außer meiner
frau
sie ist türkin
der samstag der sonntag
jeden sonntag essen wie meinen eltern
jeden sonntag essen wir bei meinen
eltern
gut
der appetit
der saft
gleich
guten appetit
möchtest du einen apfel oder orangensaft
das ist mir gleich
denn
er ihm da tief
der sala
das salz
kannst du mir bitte das messer geben
gib ihm bitte das messer
wie schmeckt dir der salat
ich finde ihn gut
das salz haben
kann ich bitte das salz haben
hier ist es
der schinken die schenken
brauchen
kennen
wunderbar
ich möchte die an ein schinkenbrot
ich mache dir 1
brauchst du den pfeffer noch
nein
wie schmeckt das essen
es schmeckt wunderbar
das zimmer
die zimmer
bereit
die zimmer sind groß
ja und die garage ist breit genug
die möbel
das sofa
das bett
die betten
sind die möbel neu
nur das sofa
der rest nicht
und wir brauchen noch ein kinderbett
der anschluss
mieten
hat das haus einen telefonanschluss
ja
dann möchte ich dieses haus mieten
der beruf
die berufe
die hausfrau
der hausmann
die maschine
die maschinen
machen
die lösung
die lösungen
und frau schmitt
was sind ihre berufe
ich bin ökonomen
er ist hausmann
er wäscht kocht und kauft ein
es gibt hier keine waschmaschine
aber keine waschmaschine
das macht nichts
wir können eine wasch einkaufen
wir können eine war maschine kaufen
das ist eine gute lösung
weiter geht's im nächsten video
[Musik]